сьогодні концерт
Верховної Ради переглянув своє рішення
досить несподіване щодо включення Петра
Порошенка до складу української
делегації до парламентської асамблеї
Ради Європи Справа в тому що взагалі-то
від нас там представлений Олексій
Гончаренко і він дуже активно там працює
але
зві- від опзж і місяць тому все-таки
комітет вирішив що цю квоту отримує
тепер найбільше наступна фракція це
європейська Солідарність вона делегувала
туди ми туди делегували Петра Порошенка
розуміючи що величезні виклики і дуже
багато роботи треба робити з європейцями
сьогодні на дипломатичному фронті і тоді
комітет це рішення підтримав але
впродовж місяця його виконання блокував
фактично спікер українського парламенту
Руслан стефанчук і не підписував склад
цієї делегації яка має вже от-от поїхати
на наступну сесію парі і сьогодні от
несподівано почалася буквально там
скандальна ситуація коли сказали Ні ми
будемо проголосувати тому що нам треба
включити представників груп Ну я нагадаю
що представники груп це мажоритарні
депутати або так само ті самі депутати і
до пзж які просто переназвалися
проходили в інших групи І от власне
кажучи було ухвалене рішення туди
послати депутата бакунця ви знаєте Ну
інакше трактувати це аніж
знаєте оці постійні постійно політичну
боротьбу як послуги народу ведуть з
лідером ЄС Петро Порошенко не можна тому
що сьогодні ми абсолютно жорстко
дотримуємося принципу
загальнонаціональної єдності ми говоримо
про те що це величезна цінність під час
війни коли там більшість українців
сьогодні Ну потерпають насправді дуже
серйозно від від війни не тільки тому що
знаходяться там в темних будівлях як я
от зараз і прошу вибачення за це що я
можу там ліхтариком собі в очі світити
щоб вийти в ефір але найперший йдеться
про фронт і найперший йдеться про його
потреби і от Порошенко якраз є тим
політиком який дуже добре знає ці
потреби фронту оскільки він був
верховним головнокомандувачем з 14 по 19
цей рік і очевидно він би міг дуже
професійно говорити про реальні потреби
українського українських військових з
усіма своїми європейськими колегами у
парі замість цього бачимо таку знаєте
внутрішньополітичну метушню і перехід до
цієї довоєнної такої боротьби яка Ну
знаєте точки зору є серйозною загрозою
сьогодні
що буде далі тобто чи є можливість все ж
таки якось достукатися до членів
комітету і я сподіваюся що далі так би
мовити хоча б здоровий глузд і інстин
самозбереження візьме
цікаво оскільки там різні сигнали
поступають і про можливість там знову
порушень якихось нових кримінальних
справ це дуже Так дивно виглядає І
взагалі Це дуже дивно чути тому що я
хочу от наприклад вам зараз сказати що
більшість кримінальних справ були
порушені
дбр за
оцими доносами
вдумайтеся ріната Кузьміна Андрія
деркача Андрія портнова Віктора
медведчука Нестора Шуфрича тобто от
чотирьох з цих п'яти вони перебувають
під американськими санкціями і вчора їх
позбавили
українського громадянства чотирьох із
цих п'яти тобто Україна визнає що це
були російські Агенти які виконували тут
замовлення ФСБ вони писали доноси в
генпрокуратуру в СБУ в дбр і ті кліпали
кримінальні справи на Порошенка як на
ворога Росії тобто вони в принципі
робили як Агенти всі свою роботу тільки
питання Одне лишається а чому
український правоохоронні органи
виконували ці задачі Хто взагалі в цьому
винен щоб не працювали під дудку
російських
фсбних агентів так от ці справи досі не
закриті і навпаки Ми чуємо про бажання
там далі знову почати оце нове коло
внутрішньополітичної боротьби тому я
дуже сподіваюся що цього не станеться І
що європейська Солідарність може далі
працювати над зміцненням оборони
здатності країни як ми це робимо від
початку повномасштабного вторгнення як
ми це зрештою робили всі з 14-го року і
Далі будемо займатися своїми
волонтерськими проектами пошуком купівлі
завезенням зброї для українських
військових частин і це спільна справа
від неї залежить виживання країни і
хотілося б займатися цим а не отаким от
дрібним політикам
якось дбр збирається щось з цими
справами робити от ви ще згаданими там
до речі справа за томос була якщо я не
помиляюсь теж щоб взагалі виглядає
оксимороном в Нових реаліях коли
православна служба України вперше за 336
років провела службу у києво-печерській
лаврі ця справа теж висить і дбр якось
реагує на звернення і відповідає щось ну
яких підставах Ну поки що принаймні
справи не закриті І я думаю що це
напевно теж же ж питання політичної волі
оскільки бояться Слухайте ну бояться Ну
от очевидно що десь хтось і якісь короти
у владі теж рухали цю тему правда І які
там курують
наші правоохоронні органи і які були
близькими
з цим її знає як
кремлівський Агенти Але я думаю що
кремлівські Агенти не тільки цей четверо
людей які вчора позбулися громадянства
України і дуже шкода До речі що вони
лише позбулися громадянства України би
хотіла щоб їх засудили бодай заочно якщо
вони вже повтікали в Росію да І хоча б
засудили за державну зраду
так легко не весь перелік тих людей які
працювали на Росію і я не хочу думати що
сьогодні
от в середовищі влади про охоронних
структур так само там полишалися люди
які
ну скажемо так мали якісь такі зв'язки
тому давайте от відділимо нарешті от
мухи від котлет Да я думаю що хто є
ворогом Росії історичним може давно
зрозуміли Це український президент і про
український президент і Віктор Ющенко і
Петро Порошенко і Володимир Зеленський
станом на зараз і всі вони є величезним
ворогом Москви Москва завжди робила все
щоб їх знищити і буде далі продовжувати
це робити от не треба в Москві
відігрувати всередині країни